maintenance ceased there's some things
that happen what the - behind the
bedroom door behind the bedroom door
you found a pregnancy test in our trash
can if you know George then ah I think
the only one like one the other time
always has to make you cry it's one way
or another Alex we finally in a trash
it's not mine not our we'll eat that's
not Alana's how is it not you because
it's not alright what other explanation
is there it's impossible we have an odd
sense okay what is the message behind
that storyline well it's about talking
it's about really talking to your kids
about their sexual health I think that a
lot of households don't I think it's
also talking about safe sex yeah she's a
nurse so this is all health-related
choir and we have a really great episode
with Alex that I really like where he
talks about not being ready which I just
think we've never really seen from male
perspective male perspective and so it's
great it's really great to have a season
where we have our very handsome boy
character decide he's not ready yet wow
that's powerful you're right cuz we
always see it from the girls not right
now but I get is amongst people I hear
like that this generation is a little
bit more they're putting that off a
little bit more and I think that's
really great okay so when you're ready
solid advice yeah what did it mean to
you to be a part of that episode telling
that story I mean for me it just it's I
guess it's just showing like one day at
a time does in many ways it's showing
that these things are normal and there's
not really one way to feel about
something just because society tells you
to feel a certain way about it so that's
I feel like it's it's always great to
have those conversations and and start
those conversations with your family
where it's like I mean if if you're not
ready or especially in a teenage you
know relationship it's good to be open
and have conversations and talk about
this because I mean you're still growing
up you're not only
of other people but you're still
learning new things about yourself so
it's it's important to to make sure that
that you're 100% okay with what you want
to do yes are you as far as Nora and
Alex's relationship is concerned what is
next
are they serious I mean they're looki
serious we have we I want to keep
filming we haven't finish the season so
I don't know what's gonna happen they
get along they're really cute together
and I and the great thing that I like
about it is that everyone gets along
everyone in the family gets scared of
like maybe you know Lydia be mean to her
like she is with yes because that would
have been a little crazy so yeah I like
them together and I feel like it starts
getting more serious every episode I
mean that's a very serious conversation
to have for two 16 year olds like I
never they're like oh we're and which
like I've never met 16 years when I was
16 I wasn't anybody being like are you
are we ready for this next step
especially the dude especially a Latino
man like it was so cool to see that
happen and Marcel portrayed it so
beautifully and hopefully it reaches
people and young men because I feel like
there's so much pressure on them you
just think that sometimes they don't
even want to do they just feel like they
have to
[Music]